[Music]
i've been told my personality can make
people uncomfortable hey how to make
love all night
well you know i think we're gonna get
along pretty well
but i've learned that if you plan for
every variable a happy outcome doesn't
have to be left to chance this
conversation's going pretty well yes
so that's no accident
everything that's happened today
i've rehearsed it hey hi nathan dozens
of times uh in a replica of your home
this is what we can do for you you and
you
you know just off the top of my head i
would say sure let's go with it this is
gonna be fun
it will be my goal is for your rehearsal
to reflect reality
the government has sasquatch liaisons
i love you daddy
with this show if your performance isn't
accurate you could ruin someone's life
this is all sort of absurd
keep them crying don't let out okay i've
got to tell you something i don't want
to talk to you again do you find it's
been healthy for you here
are you sure you want to do this
i don't really like lying to people
you're a liar yeah neither do i
you're willy wonka and charlie bucket
i'm the bad guy well but he's a dream
maker okay and you're doing you're
making some dreams happen but the kids
died in the factory well they supposedly
died either i'll read the book again
just to
to look into it
[Music]
you